thank you so much for honoring me with
this award I'm sorry for what so ho the
Oscars it's a show that I probably would
have stopped watching if I didn't you
know have an Oscar party that I went to
every year and wasn't in an Oscar fooled
if it wasn't for that I probably want to
stop watching this over a decade ago but
the Academy Awards is a thing that still
happens and it's going through some
changes now before I get into these I
can tell you that the big we found out
since the announcement last week that
these pushes these changes were pushed
for by ABC the network that airs the
Oscars so the reasoning behind these is
completely and utterly obvious and
transparent and that is these are moves
to try and help the ratings because the
ratings have just not been good for a
while and that's you know regardless of
anything else going on they're just
they're not there and it's not hard to
figure out why it's a long show and a
lot of the awards that are up are not
particularly well known to viewers so
they don't care well they're doing a
couple of things to try and rectify that
one thing is they're adopting the model
of the Tony Awards with their broadcast
which is things that aren't like the
major awards you know the acting the
best picture maybe screenwriting and
things like that those are gonna happen
I'm not aired live I think what they
said was they're gonna do them like
during the commercial breaks and then
coming back from the break that like put
up who won cuz I'll still need to know
cuz usually the Oscar fools make you
make or break whether or not you win on
those tiny frigging categories
especially the technical ones those are
usually easy to call if you're paying
attention but that is one thing so that
should theoretically shorten the
broadcast
remove some of the categories that I'm
sorry nobody outside the interest yeah
nobody outside the industry cares about
I mean your average home viewer doesn't
care who wins best sound mixing and
that's not me saying somebody shouldn't
get an award for best sound mixing sound
makes is actually crazy important and
when it's wrong it ruins the whole thing
they absolutely deserve the award but if
you're talking your numbers and the
broadcast of the thing yeah no I get
that
the the much more desperate scented idea
that they're gonna be doing is they're
introducing a new category that looks
like it's gonna be called achievements
in popular film don't ask me what that
actually means of what that will
actually translate to what the
requirements are or anything because
that hasn't been made clear yet what is
clear from the name alone is this is a
category for blockbusters basically the
movies that everybody sees but never get
nominated so this would be your
superhero movies your big-budget action
movies this is where your your Marvel
movies and your James Bond's and your
fast and furious and your star wars and
those things would end up here giving a
category with nominees that that the
average viewer is more likely to care
about and therefore more likely to watch
and on paper that makes a lot of sense
but boy the context of all this is it's
kind of pathetic because the the reason
this whole shift to quote-unquote
oscar movies not being movies that are
particularly popular with mass audience
is a relatively recent trend i mean you
you go back you know really kind of back
to the 80s and before that the major
nominees at least a decent chunk of them
would be films that were notable box
office successes the first Star Wars
movie had Oscar
nominations like major ones best picture
people forget that you would assume that
that would never get a nomination today
and it wouldn't because the shift
happened over time and unfortunately in
many ways you can blame of all people
the Weinsteins for this because they
really sort of weaponized and and
rebuilt and established what a winning
oscar for your consideration campaign
looks like they did that you know in the
90s and that was a big part of what the
strength of Miramax was built on was its
award-winning potential because they
they weren't making huge blockbusters
they weren't doing huge numbers but they
were winning awards because they knew
how to work the system they knew how to
push and they knew how to get things
that would tickle the Academy members
fancy and oftentimes out the expense of
mainstream appeal but they didn't care
because that's not who they were making
it for so that overtook things and even
since having expanded out the the
category of Best Picture which they
started doing in 2009 that all that's
really done is opened up the field a
little bit more for the nominees but it
hasn't resulted in any major shakeups
for the actual award winners you know so
something like district 9 can say it was
nominated for a Best Picture but it was
never gonna win so the thing is I get
it's it's just such a band-aid fix
because the problem the Academy has is
that the system as it exists for both
nominees and winning is there the
problems are embedded in that system the
system as it exists and again this was
an evolution that happened over time
over decades it didn't happen suddenly
if it happens suddenly they could fix it
with with one or two moves they can't
but it is now systemic in the system
that smaller films released in November
or December that
don't get wide releases are your major
nominees that's the way the system works
now and trying to undo that well I'll be
honest it would be something that will
probably be worth doing but I get a
sense they're not even gonna try and
even if they are trying to undo that and
shift that it's gonna take too long and
they need something faster now because
the ratings are in the toilet now so but
this this this is such a band-aid
because the propogation need to fix are
much bigger than having a popular films
category and that just comes across as
so patronizing because it's like this
thing of oh the public won't watch our
intellectual award show will fine give
them their own category of the popular
films maybe that'll make them happy at
that I'm projecting a little bit I
understand that but like it's hard for
me not to read it like that it really
does it I mean if I'm not gonna read it
like that then I'm read it as oh for the
love of God here's some films you care
about just watch us and neither one of
those is an appealing thing to me and
the other thing that I don't love is the
fact that regardless of this new
category the Academy itself it can't be
changed overnight
it's these same people it has the same
members and they are doing things about
that there are things that have been
changed over time in terms of who can
and can't actually vote as a standing
Academy member and some of those moves I
think are going to yield good results
but it's going to take time because it
has to do with phasing out some folks
said while bringing other folks into the
into the system but and like I said that
will take time but in the meantime this
whole thing it's oh man you know what I
feel like this is gonna turn into a lot
of ways what the best animated film
category is because like I said it's
these same people until they get the
actual voting base shifted around
better than because if you look at the
animation category the best animated
feature basically whatever was the
biggest hit usually Pixar wins because
the Academy voting members are not
they're not animation aficionados
they're gonna go oh what one did my kid
like are more likely given the age of
your average Academy remember what one
did my grandkid like and I have a
feeling that the popular films category
is going to be much of the same thing
it's going to be basically an award for
having the highest profile which is why
Pixar dominates you know the Animation
Awards every year even when they don't
deserve to be brave girl
so I just I I can't I can't take this
seriously
it's so transparent and attempt to reach
out and gain viewership and attention
and it's one that I cannot imagine the
Academy actually takes seriously as a
category because like I said the the
voters are gonna it's gonna be our
bridge almost arbitrary but they pick
and then in addition to that it's by
having a category called achievement in
popular film the subtext of that is here
are all the awards for greatness and
here's your popular crap that you people
like we wouldn't award this otherwise
but here here's your special category
for popular junk I'm sure they don't
want it to come across like that but
that's how it does and I'm not sure what
else there is to say it's I just find it
kind of funny I really feel bad for
whoever I still host the Oscars this
year and set up this category for them
they're really gonna have to talk it up
big I'm sure it'll be part of the intro
and the you know the opening monologue
segment and it'll be brought up
repeatedly like I feel really bad for
whoever has to has to sell this to
viewers and I'll tell you what I will be
curious
keep an eye on what actually gets in
there and tried to because like I said
they ever released the criteria and they
might not because they're they're kind
of vague about that a lot of ways
anyways really the only time we hear
about the specific criteria is when
something done isn't allowed in that one
would expect to like we had to get down
to the criteria as to why the lego movie
didn't get a nomination so you know
things like that but other than that we
don't get a lot of peaking behind the
curtains so I will be curious to see if
they just basically pick the top five
grossing movies of that year or if
there's a little more thought put into
it than that so maybe there's my tiny
like miniscule asterisks like I don't I
can't take this seriously
I appreciate the move and I appreciate
this is the situation that the Academy
is in at least as far as the broadcast
goes that they kind of have to do
something and they can't wait for the
long term fakes of of making the
adjustments to the membership and the
voting habits and the campaigning habits
because that it takes time to correct
the the internal workings of the
apparatus it's pretty easy just to slap
a sporty sticker on the outside of the
vehicle and go hey so that's basically
what this is so those are my thoughts on
the new category achievement in popular
phoom what are your thoughts on whatever
they are drops on me down in the
comments let's talk about it there's
stuff to do you know what it is links
for all that stuff is down in the
description I have a picture on the big
one all that's the only one I'll single
out so remember folks you are the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]